what are the first words that come to
mind when you think of Facebook as a
whole maybe powerful ubiquitous privacy
intrusion now what are the first words
that come to mind when you think about
the OG Facebook platform old dead out of
fashion maybe well you're not alone this
sentiment seems to be pretty common
online especially amongst younger
Generations the general theme seems to
be that Facebook used to be something
that was popular way back in the late
2000s and the early 20110
but since then it has largely fallen out
of favor and Google Trends simply
confirms this idea interest in Facebook
today is only a mere 16% of what it used
to be back in 2012 so it's a good thing
that Facebook bought Instagram and
WhatsApp and evolve their business right
well there's no arguing that Instagram
and WhatsApp weren't Stellar
Acquisitions but what might surprise you
is that Facebook is still more lucrative
than WhatsApp and Instagram combined
in fact OG Facebook is still the most
lucrative social media in the entire
world by a long shot in 2023 for example
Facebook is expected to pull in over $70
billion in revenue for perspective
YouTube only pulls in 30 billion Tik Tok
only pulls in $13 billion and the
Twitter only pulls in $4.7 billion the
only platform that even comes close is
Instagram at $50 billion but even
Instagram is a full 20 billion dollars
behind Facebook and that's just looking
at Topline numbers if we look at Revenue
per user Facebook becomes even more wild
it turns out that Facebook still somehow
has 3 billion monthly active users the
highest of any social media platform as
such their revenue per user is $23 per
year for perspective Tik Tok stands at
about $8 per user and even YouTube only
stands at $11 per user so who exactly
are all these people people who are
still using OG Facebook and how has meta
managed to keep Facebook so profitable
despite the overall
[Music]
sentiment one of the biggest secret
weapons of Facebook is the time period
in which it was founded at this point
it's been nearly 20 years since Facebook
was founded which isn't all that long
for a company but it's basically eons
for a social network in fact Facebook is
by far the oldest social media that's
still relevant to this day everything
else from that era whether it's MSN
Messenger or Myspace are completely dead
Facebook actually started off as a
Tinder sort of platform originally it
was called a face mash and it allowed
Harvard students to rate their peers in
terms of attractiveness when you visited
their website you would get two pictures
side by side and you would get to choose
who is more attractive fun fact
Zuckerberg actually almost got expelled
from Harvard due to face Mash as harv
felt that the website violated their
students privacy and security sounds
like some things just never change but
anyway face mash and later Facebook were
obviously a Young Person's website I
mean I can't imagine any normal 40 or
50-year-old playing this game but here's
the thing it's not just Facebook that
has grown old over the years but also
all of its users if you were 20 to 30
when Facebook came out you're now 40 to
50 and for the longest time this was
actually seen as a massive disadvantage
to stay relevant social media networks
are constantly trying to get newer
Generations on board YouTube has managed
to do a pretty good job of this given
that YouTube is commonly used by people
of all age groups Tik Tok on the other
hand very much skews towards younger
demographics as you would expect in fact
nearly 70% of Tik Tok users are under
the age of 35 Facebook however largely
sked towards older demographics their
most popular demographics is age 25 to
34 4 and nearly half of all Facebook
users are above the age of 35 which is
basically unheard of when it comes to
social media but while it may not be
cool to have a platform filled with
people over the age of 35 it turns out
that it's rather lucrative given that
this demographic is a lot more likely to
have money in fact for people under the
age of 35 the media net worth is only
$39,000 but when you jump up to the 35
to 44 bracket this over triples to $13
$5,000 and that's just the median the
average goes up to
$550,000 and it only goes up from there
up until age 75 and we see a similar
story when we take a look at the income
of people using these platforms with
YouTube for example it's actually less
likely that you use YouTube with growing
income 76% of people making less than
$50,000 per year use YouTube but only
69% of people making 50 to 100,000 use
YouTube and only 65% of people making
making over $100,000 use YouTube this
isn't to say that only broke people
watch YouTube but rather that YouTube
tends to be watched more by students and
young adults who don't yet have
substantial income with Facebook on the
other hand there seems to be no
correlation between income and usage in
fact whether you're making less than
$30,000 per year or over $100,000 per
year there's about an 86% chance that
you use Facebook for obvious reasons
this is a much more valuable audience to
Market to than teenagers and college
students leading to far more ad revenue
for Facebook per user than any other
platform but all of that only tells half
the story as Facebook has an even more
powerful
[Music]
secret every Tech company's dream is to
build an everything app like we chat in
China but most efforts to do so in the
west simply end up falling flat it turns
out that people simply don't want
certain things to be connected and that
separation is often not only useful but
desired in fact one of the main reasons
that Instagram Snapchat and eventually
Tik Tok grew in popularity is because it
wasn't connected to Facebook teenagers
and young adults are naturally not drawn
to a social media platform that their
parents also use but while Facebook
hasn't been able to create an everything
app across Generations or across
Industries it does seem like Facebook
has actually been doing pretty well in
terms of creating an everything social
media app for their core demographic
personally I've never used Facebook
messaging and I don't know even a single
person who does everyone around me just
uses iMessage Instagram DMS or maybe
even WhatsApp but it turns out that
messaging friends and family is actually
the number one reason that people use
Facebook amongst Facebook's core
demographic 72% of users use Facebook
for messaging which is over two billion
people by the way and that's just
messaging 1.9 billion people use it to
share photos and videos similar to
Instagram and YouTube 1.7 billion people
use it to keep up to date with news and
current events similar to Twitter and
1.6 billion people even use it to watch
memes into funny content similar to Tik
Tok if you didn't know it's not just
Instagram that has reals Facebook does
too so it seems that Facebook has
created this sort of Niche super app
that's a combination of Instagram
WhatsApp YouTube Twitter iMessage and
even Tik Tok that are all super popular
amongst the people who actually use
Facebook this not only gives Facebook a
lot of control but also a lot of
Versatility when it comes to ads they're
not limited to any one format like
YouTube for example pretty much the only
control you have when it comes to
YouTube ads is how long the ad is and
whether it's skiable or not but that's
pretty much it Facebook on the other
hand is able to accommodate for image
ads video ads Carousel ads instant
experiences and collections not to
mention they have several sub formats
under each of these larger formats in
other words on the advertiser side of
things Facebook is able to appeal to all
sorts of advertisers and on the user
side of things they can push ad through
all sorts of formats so basically
Facebook is super popular amongst an
older richer demographic that use
Facebook for all of their social media
needs and advertisers are able to reach
these people through any medium they
want I think you can start to see just
why Facebook is so darn lucrative but
how sustainable really is
[Music]
this having a rich older demographic
that's loyal is great for the time being
but eventually these people will grow
out of the platform right I mean it's no
secret that as you grow older you spend
less time on social media the internet
and Tech in general
right well that has definitely been the
trend over the past few decades but
correlation does not indicate causation
older demographics not using social
media is often chocked up to people
simply growing out of it but as we can
see with Facebook's demographics people
don't necessarily grow out of social
media as such I suspect that older
demographics not using social media
actually has to do with other aspects
first of all people simply get busier as
they grow older they're working harder
than ever they have kids they have to
maintain their homes and all of that on
average people between the ages of 35
and 44 have the least amount of leisure
time of any age group but after this age
Leisure Time starts to grow once again
people get to a comfortable position in
their careers their kids go off to
college they pay off their homes and so
on by the time that they're 65 their
leisure time is higher than ever and it
seems that historically all of this free
time had just been filled up with more
TV but but I think a lot of this simply
has to do with lifelong influences when
Baby Boomers and the silent generation
were growing up TVs were just starting
to become popular and that stuck with
them similarly as Millennials and
younger gen xers were growing up social
media was just starting to get popular
and that may very well stick with them I
mean we can already see this playing out
if you ask anyone under the age of 30
about Facebook they'll likely respond
with who even uses Facebook nowadays in
fact that's probably why a lot of you
clicked on this video you assume that
Facebook is on its way out but it turns
out that over 3 billion people use
Facebook on a monthly basis much of whom
are over the age of 35 of course their
use of the platform has evolved over
time they're no longer ranking whether
their peers are Hot or Not instead
they're in Facebook groups with their
friends family and neighbors and they
talk about their kids going up or having
to replace their roof for local events
and I don't think this will change in
fact as Facebook's core demographic
grows older and starts having more
leisure time they may actually start
using Facebook even more similar to how
older Generations started to watch TV
more in other words Facebook could very
well be the first social media platform
that's used primarily by people in their
50s 60s and' 7s because For the First
time we're seeing a tech liter
generation reach those ages also that's
not as far away as you might think the
oldest Millennials are about to turn 44
years old meaning that 50 is just around
the corner social media usage for people
over the age of 65 for example has
already quadrupled over the past decade
and I think that number will only grow
as new generations reach those ages now
of course this doesn't solve the problem
of what will happen to Facebook after
Millennials but what it does show is
that Facebook may very well stay
dominant for a lot longer than anyone
initially expected and in the meantime
Millennials and younger genxers should
simp simply get richer and richer and
have more free time to spend up until
retirement at least so while it may seem
like Facebook is heading out the door
it's very possible that everything we've
seen so far is only half the story and
we're about to witness a social media
Evolution like never before with
historically High interest rates the
appeal of bills and bonds is higher than
ever yet traditional brokerages haven't
really adapted with the times they still
expect people to use clunky Bond tables
scroll through long overwhelming lists
and even use Virtual keyboards till
recently and that's why we created our
own modern Bond platform Silo at Silo we
prioritize the user experience and the
ease of finding and investing in the
issuers you know and trust so that you
too can easily lock in high yields also
choosing a strong user experience does
not mean sacrificing unsafety every Salo
account is insured by $500,000 in sipc
insurance and it $2.5 million in FDIC
Insurance also all funds deposited on
the platform will be maintained by our
trusted custodian interactor brokers who
has experienced managing $373 billion
worth of assets over the past 45 years
so if you're looking for a modern way to
invest in bonds please consider checking
out Silo in the description below
Facebook isn't the only meta platform
that's killing it Instagram is also
killing it check out this video to learn
more but until then I'm Hari and I'll
see see you guys on the next
[Music]
one